- Hi, everyone.
Sal Khan here from Khan Academy.
I just wanted to welcome you
to National SAT Practice Test Day.
Now, a lot of you probably are putting
a lot of weight into the Sat.
It is an input into the
college admissions process,
but the one thing I wanna
emphasize is more important
than the SAT or your score is your ability
to practice, your ability
to develop yourself
and how college ready you can be.
And one thing that I've seen
in my life over and over again,
and I've seen in many other people's lives
is the more that you focus on the process
versus the outcome.
One, the more enjoyable it will be,
but also you'll probably
get a better outcome.
So as you go into National
SAT Practice Test Day,
and eventually as you
go into the real SAT,
or really if you go into
anything in your life
that might feel important,
focus on the process
and when you do so you'll
get into kind of a Zen Mode
and it's really starts
to get a little bit fun.
So take that mindset into the SAT,
put your best effort, get into the flow,
get into that zone if you
will, and do the best you can,
but don't get fixated
on what the outcome is.
So with that said, let's get started.
- Thanks Sal.
Hi, everyone.
I'm Lauren from Khan Academy.
Before we get to the practice test,
I want us to note that we're
giving away some prizes
for our live attendees today.
So be sure to check
out the notes on screen
and follow the instructions to enter.
We're giving away five, one
hour SATs tutoring sessions
with our SAT practice content expert.
And we're also giving your
way 10 $25 Amazon gift cards.
Okay everyone, let's get started
on your full full-length practice test.
The first step is to
log into your official
SAT practice account on Khan Academy.
So go to khanacademy.org/sat
and sign into your account.
If you don't have an account,
you can create one for free
in just a couple of minutes.
I'm already signed in.
So I'm going to click, let's go.
And once you're logged in,
you can go ahead and click on
Full Tests at the top here.
Today we're recommending
that you take practice test number 10,
which is the first test you'll see
after you click on Full Tests.
Practice tests number 10
is a newest practice test
on our site.
And like most of our practice tests,
it was previously given
as a real SAT exam.
So it'll give you a great
idea of what to expect
when you take the SAT in a few weeks.
If you've already taken
practice tests number 10,
you can choose one of
these other practice tests
to take that you haven't taken before.
Before we start the practice tests,
I want you to take a minute
and make sure you have
everything you need.
So you should have a
pen or a pencil nearby
along with some scratch paper,
so you can make notes
as you work through your math problems.
You also wanna have an approved calculator
for the final math sections,
and you can go to
collegeboard.com to learn about
what calculators are
approved for the test.
Generally, most graphing calculators,
all scientific calculators
and all four-function
calculators are approved.
So whatever calculator you have today,
that will be just fine
for the practice test.
Another thing important thing to do
is eliminate as many
distractions as possible.
So make sure your phone is
off or set to Do Not Disturb
and make sure you're in a
quiet, comfortable space
where you can really focus
on your practice tests.
Also, if you're using a laptop,
make sure it's plugged in
so that you don't have to
worry about the battery dying.
Next, let's take a minute to get over
the structure of the test.
So you know what to expect.
The first section is reading
and it is 65 minutes long.
Then we'll take a 10-minute break.
The next section is writing and language
and it is 35 minutes long.
Right after that section,
we'll move into the math,
no calculator section,
which is 25 minutes long.
Then we'll take a five-minute break.
Then you'll return for the final section,
which is the math with calculator section,
which is 55 minutes long.
We won't be adding in the
optional essay section today,
but you can practice the
essay on Khan Academy
after the practice test, if you'd like to.
So we'll have a timer running
on the screen for each section
that you can refer to.
And just like when you take the real SAT,
you'll hear me announce when
we reached the halfway point
of each section, and when you
have five minutes remaining.
I know it's a big commitment
to take a three-hour test
on a Saturday, but going
through the full test
in one sitting is really
a great way to prepare
for the test experience.
So I applaud all of you
for being here today
and taking the time.
So as you're getting
ready to start the test,
stop (indistinct) a minute and think about
what your goal is on
the practice test today.
Maybe you wanna improve your
pacing in a certain section,
or maybe there's a certain benchmark score
you're hoping to improve,
or maybe you just wanna get a sense
of what the full test is like.
Whatever your goal is
just take a quick minute
and write it down on your scratch paper
and we'll revisit it at the end.
All right, so we're ready.
So let's everyone take a deep breath,
relax and let's get started.
Please begin now.
You have 35 minutes
remaining in this section.
You have 25 minutes
You have 20 minutes
remaining in this section.
You have 15 minutes
You have five minutes
remaining in this section.
Stop work on this section.
Congratulations on completing
the reading section.
Now it's time for your 10 minute break.
So grab a snack, use the restroom,
get up and stretch for a bit.
And we'll see you back here in 10.
All right, everyone break is over.
So it's time to get back to your computers
and get ready for section two.
Let's get started.
Please begin the writing
and language section now.
You have 15 minutes
remaining in this section.
You have five minutes
Stop work on this section.
Please begin the math, no
calculator section now.
You have 15 minutes
remaining in this section.
You have five minutes
Stop work on this section.
Great job.
You've completed three
out of four sections.
Now it's time for your five minute break.
Be sure to stand up and walk around
and get a drink of water.
You're in the home stretch.
We'll see you back here in five minutes.
All right, everyone,
time to get back to your
computers for the final section,
get your calculator ready
and let's get started.
Please begin the math
calculator section now.
You have 35 minutes
remaining in this section.
You have 25 minutes
You have 20 minutes
remaining in this section.
You have 15 minutes
You have five minutes
remaining in this section.
Stop work on this section.
Congratulations, everyone.
You just completed a
full-length practice test.
Now I know you're
probably tired right now.
So after you've had some
time to rest and relax,
I highly encourage you
to come visit the test
that you just took
so that you can go over
what you've got right,
and what you missed, and you
can see what you need to study.
And as we wrap up this Practice Test Day
I want you to think back
to that goal you wrote down
when we first started.
Do you think you achieved that goal?
Why or why not?
Just take a few quick
moments to reflect on that
and consider how this might
affect your future plans
as you study for the SAT.
Thanks again for participating
in the event today.
And before you go, don't
forget to enter our raffle
where you can have a chance to win one
of our free one hour tutoring sessions
or $25 Amazon gift cards.
Have a great day, take care.
And bye for now.